[Music]
hey everyone this is Meg from Fandango
movie clips my top 10 Academy Award
winners past and present Oscar season is
upon us
and what better way to get ready for the
red carpet and to watch some of the
greats
number 10 lieutenant Dan's favorite
soldier Forrest Gump Robert Zemeckis
takes the audience on a memorable
journey spanning years and years and
years of the same haircut I'm not a
smart man Tom Hanks stole my heart with
his oscar-winning performance and taught
me that laughs like a box of chocolates
and Haley Joel Osment should have never
grown up number 9
my favorite film adaptation of a
Broadway musical West Side Story replace
the fancy Shakespeare with catchy tunes
and it's the Romeo and Juliet we get in
1961 at 110 Oscars the most ever for a
musical Wow hey cool man real cool
number 8 the one and only x-rated winner
Midnight Cowboy while failing to become
a successful male prostitute the cowboy
John Boy finds an unlikely friend in the
rat Dustin Hoffman proving no one in the
Big Apple likes a naked cowboy for tuve
tourists I'm shocked neither boy or
Hoffman brought home Oscars for their
noteworthy performances number 7 Good
Will Hunting thank you for educating the
world on the phrase I like their max and
teaching us how to correctly pronounce
pack the car at Harvard Yard my favorite
Boston boys Matt Damon and Ben Affleck
wrote an awesome script scoring them an
Oscar and the incomparable genius Robin
Williams took home the golden man for
his supporting role number 6 you'd be
nuts not to love my next pick the 1975
Best Picture winner One Flew Over the
Cuckoo's Nest Jack Nicholson's breakout
roles Mac won him an Oscar and brought
the beanie game to a whole new level
nurse ratchet played by Louise Fletcher
won for being the biggest [ __ ] in the
world number 5 I'm oh so serious about
this next pick
taking superhero movies to a new height
with dark knight Heath Ledger won for
his legendary performance as a Joker
Christopher Nolan's masterpiece broke
records as the most
it film based off of a comic book
opening the door for guardians of the
galaxy gimmick yeah well let's do it
let's do it Oscars number four the most
influential movie of the 90s slash ever
Pulp Fiction directed by one of my
favorite directors Quentin Tarantino his
eccentric violent addictive thrill ride
captivates us from start to finish
goddamn I said god damn it's a great
film it has one of the best soundtracks
of all time and one Tarantino his first
Oscar for screenwriting and it made
everyone do this at any party they've
ever gone to number three the 2010 Best
Picture winner The Hurt Locker I think
Kathryn Bigelow brilliantly captured the
complexities of wartime following the
life of a u.s. bomb dispenser in Iraq
she also became the first female
director to win an Oscar because it
takes guts to direct a film not balls
what number two Francis Ford Coppola is
the Godfather in my opinion the best
film franchise in history except for
that third one watch it or you'll wake
up with a horse head in your bed you
guys know they used a real horse in that
scene oh pretty Knicks T Marlon Brando
famously declined his Best Actor what
apparently it was an offer he could
refuse and my number one Academy
award-winning film past and present is
the 1939 Best Picture classic Gone with
the Wind frankly my dear I don't give a
damn if you don't agree with me this
long dramatic Civil War saga taught me
very important life lessons like if you
want a man's attention slap them across
the face that's my list of the top ten
Academy award-winning films past and
present comment below and let me know
your favorite winners I make from
Fandango movie clips thanks for watching
and don't forget to tune in to the 87th
Academy Awards
[Music]
[Music]